ça y est elle est là vague la cinquième
vague la cinquième vague on espérait en
avoir bel et bien finie mais la
cinquième vague de l'épidémie de
couronnes à virus a démarré cette
cinquième vague sera sans conteste plus
forte plus longue que la quatrième vague
survenus cet été après près de 32000
nouvelles contaminations par jour le
gouvernement a dû prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles pour minimiser les
hospitalisations en france le taux
d'incidence sur sept jours-- dépasse
deux cent soixante-dix pour cent mille
habitants alors qu'il est de 48 et demi
au niveau mondial ce midi olivier doran
a pris la parole pour annoncer ses
mesures à savoir une troisième dose pour
tous les adultes cinq mois après la
précédente injection les tests pcr
désormais valable 24 heures au lieu de
48 heures et le retour du masque dans
tous les lieux couverts il faut donc
rester vigilant à tout instant de
nouvelles réflexions qui divise déjà
alors cinquième bague et annonce de
olivier derand êtes vous convaincu
fabrice di vizio est de retour et ba ty
visio et de tous
[Musique]
fabrice
[Rires]
rien il faut plus rien penser il faut
obéir ça va vous pas moi qui l'ait dit
scellier verront qu'il a dit il a dit la
liberté c'est d'obéir au risque d'être
banni de la société c'est clair non la
liberté c'est d'obéir au loin au risque
d'être banni de la société bah ça
s'appelle une dictature
ah ça y est vous avez je suis désolé en
philosophie politique salins ce qui
vient il faut relire antigone c'est
exactement ça rigole et on frais c'est
la définition la dictature quand on me
dit que ma seule liberté c'est celle de
billets de la ferme et on risque d'être
mis au ban de la société bah ça
s'appelle une dictature appelez la comme
vous voulez mais en en philosophie
politique la littérature donc voila moi
je ne le but n'est pas que je pense quoi
que ce soit on attend de moi que je
devais hills où je suis mis au bond et
même pas de problème je suis mis au ban
alors à partir de ce samedi le rappel
vaccinal sera ouvert à tous les adultes
des cinq mois après leur dernière
injection on parle aussi du test du test
il sera valable que 24 heures maintenant
que 62 eur 24 heures bon ça pour obliger
les gens à vacciner
tous les jours donc la dernière nuit
mais non attention le conseil d'état
vous avez dit que c'était interdit mais
il fallait surtout pas que de passes
sanitaire n'ait pour objet ou pour effet
de pousser à la vaccination surtout pas
qu'il fallait effectivement que ce soit
aux strictes afin de lutter contre
l'épidémie sauf que finalement depuis eh
ben on a découvert que ce qui
différencie la dictature de la
démocratie c'est la notion de fins
savait que en démocratie le moyen compte
autant que la faim en dictature on se
fout un peu plus les moyens de le manque
la fin on estime que la faille bonne
points et ben je suis désolé aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai problème cette histoire de
test c'est un vrai problème qu'est ce
que ça veut dire l'histoire du test
concrètement ça veut dire que vous allez
avoir des gens qui dans les hôpitaux qui
vont voir leurs enfants parce que
maintenant les exige aussi dans les
hôpitaux pédiatriques de manière
illégale 1 on va aller voir des enfants
toutes les 24 heures et à part se faire
tester et à quelles fins pour quoi faire
donc moi qui je peux avec ciné je
m'excite je me faisais qu'il allait
faire bah moi rien de ce que vous en
faites vacciner et mais moi je m'en fout
en fait vous fait j'écris tous les deux
à moi de faire mon football société je
l'avais vous avez évolué parce que vous
vouliez pas qu'on conçoit pas testé nous
même si on était vacciné mais
non j'ai pas eu peur non non vous n'êtes
pas compris un truc c'est qu'en fait je
m'en fous du volant comme demandé rien
vous n'êtes pas compris moi m'a rien
demandé en venant ici m non non non non
non on m'a rien demandé en venant ici
moi je n'ai pas fait de personnes
étaient à bord du bateau de se faire
tester non est ce que j'ai dit c'est
quand je suis arrivé sur le plateau pour
finir ici on m'a demandé mon avis mais
un aaa c'est pas possible remarque mme
asma possible si moi j'ai demandé les
chronos moi j'étais un homme attablé
tout ce que vous voulez m'engager sur ce
terrain-là engageons-nous sur ce terrain
là dedans bleu et rose moi j'avais une
offre si vous voulez moi j'avais dit je
veux bien de soumettre impasse si tout
le monde s'y soumet ça a été très clair
mais à partir du moment où vous me le
demandez pas vous faites exactement ce
que vous voulez je m'en fous moi il m'a
aimé comment ça je m'en enfin de la
rappelle t on est le nom du grand
tournai la dernière fois il fallait tout
ce qu'on est à stationner dans le nez
avec un familier pour vous montrer en
valeur négatif ou que vous foutez nous
alors vous n'avez pas pourquoi ça n'est
pas loin de leur est exactement mais moi
c'est votre problème juste à côté bah
oui
on peut afficher aujourd'hui
qu'est cette forme de dictature progrès
que nous le fassions nous l'apprennent
devez tous vous faire plaisir parce que
nous sommes n'est pas du tout joué le
coi attendait mais pas du tout il ya
même un pourcentage de français
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont encore peur de se
faire vacciner effectivement même ce
problème qui
sont vaccinés se transmettent c'est bien
pour ça que vous nous aidez
nous à demander à tous d'avoir un papier
devant nous on a fait un test pc et
s'efface que excusez moi pourquoi il a
fait ça là dans la fois fabrice renner
pas du tout finie parce que c'est pas
moi tu me fais vacciner transmettre le
virus concernant le cas aujourd'hui
alors bas c'est pour ça qu'on
dit aujourd'hui
il s'écoule demandes pour venir dans
l'émission
ne demandant pas sanitaire voilà le
vaccin monsieur m du maillot disait que
ça n'était pas suffisant voilà on
voulait le vaccin pour les doublons mais
en fait que je vous ai je pas c'est
quand que j'étais les six maintenant d
re vous mentez
d'alors sous les bombes et les faits
l'accusé moi mais vous apprécié l'équipe
et moi dans un pré synodal mais il me
semble aujourd'hui que je suis mieux
réagir aux annonces de différents moi je
vous dis que j'avais toujours dit à
cyril je vais résumer mon avenir fois si
tu me demandes impasse anita pour venir
je ne viens pas points au départ on a
dit tu as le rayonnement rotois hockey
après on m'avait retourné sur le
trottoir vadim avait un voulait
retourner sur lequel nul part je m'en
fous moi bien d'accord je m'en fous
complètement du moment qu'on me demande
rien borel je refuse de me soumettre le
pass annie terre pour venir je veux pas
c'est à dire donc si je le fais mais
vous avez peut-être s'avoue sastre ans
c'est un c'est pas du tout non c'est pas
ça qu'on est avec les soldats sionistes
se juge au truc que j'ai dit mais la
maison camilo
fulham et martine vassal
ou sous les bombes on est sur du goudron
trucs et ils m'ont
soulevé ne lui parlez pas et ben voilà
c'est bien nous passer alors oui
je voulais savoir pourquoi ils ne
voulaient pas ça va actionner
intéressant de savoir deux choses
pourquoi je peux faire c'est pourquoi je
pas dû passer la nuit parce qu'il est
libre allocution de ba ba oui mais les
odeurs
alors que farid vacciner parce que moi
je
négocie pas que les terroristes dire la
vaccination imposé en vrille couteau je
ne fais pas ça personne ne m'écoute
hausse est un peu forte et
personne n'est mort
par les mots que j'utilise peuvent ne
pas vous convenir mais tant qu'ils sont
les lire je vais continuer d'utiliser
vous êtes libre à utiliser avec les
sondés placent et le pouvez opter berlin
jugé qu'on en parle quand on regarde
ensuite effectivement pourquoi je refuse
le patac reçu de vaccination néanmoins
sur un autre poids c'est qu'aujourd'hui
je me permets de rappeler à qui veut
l'entendre que nous sommes sur une
autorité autorisation de mise sur le
marché conditionnel que ce vaccin
effectivement deux bénéficient d'aucun
recul que nous découvrons des effets
secondaires de jour en jour de mois en
mois qui n'ont pas été répertorié que
concrètement la troisième dose par
exemple n'a pas elle a fait l'objet
d'aucune étude en double aveugle même
pas d'étude du tout que l'accélération
des cinq ans est une aberration
absolument crest recul nous avons en
santé publique qu'est mon métier a
priori aujourd'hui très clairement cette
vaccination telle qu'elle est opéré
aujourd'hui est un scandale sanitaire
nous ne voyons pas encore mais nous
allons le voir ici quelques années parce
que le propre et c'est claude l1 qui
écrivait on ne sait qu'une chose arrive
que quand déjà elle est arrivée au lever
1 paul
moi je moi si vous voulez en tant que
tel aujourd'hui on aurait d'autres
pistes et notre solution qui aurait pu
être intéressante ç'aurait été de libéra
s'attendre d'autres vaccins et livre
ailleurs c'est ce que j'observe que
c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire en
guadeloupe par exemple alors c'est une
solution partiellement satisfaisante
pour seulement mais néanmoins
aujourd'hui obligé des pertes de 12 ans
de 15 ans de 20 ans à se faire vacciner
tout en nous disant que c'est fait juste
pour protéger les formes graves alors
qu'elles ne font pas de forme grave si
ça c'est pas se [ __ ] du monde sait
quand même qu'il ya un problème quelque
part alors s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur les
annonces gilles verdez sur sur les 12 15
ans ça ça pose énormément poèmes suis
beaucoup plus on réagira là dessus
fabrice failli il n'est pas le seul à
dire ça il est pas ça mais moi je trouve
qu'il ya des points qui semblent être
sur lesquels je le rejoins c'est à dire
que ce pass sanitaire en fait est une
hypocrisie pour moi dans les annonces ça
devient un pass vaccinale persie va
maintenant à 24 heures oui donc ans avec
le choix et on nous le dit pas vraiment
et en fait c'est un pass vaccinale et je
suis assez d'accord que les gens qui
pour des raisons qui aa mme à mon avis
assez bonne sympa je crois le baila wane
5 euros et 1 centime moi tu te rends
compte ou pas 25 euros jour les gens qui
ne veulent pas se vacciner sont
ostracisés ils sont mis au monde 11 juin
je vous rejoins alors qu'il saignait au
bond et puis les moteurs est d'accord
avait pas et sait pas c'est parce qu'ils
avaient été annoncées exactement
d'impôts ces annonces avaient
clairement une hypocrisie le
gouvernement dit non c'est pas vrai on
ne met pas en place un pass vaccinale
mais si c'est clairement un pass
vaccinale certes et non seulement on
interdit aux gens de vivre s'ils ne sont
pas vaccinés c'est à dire manger et
sortir travailler et on paye même pour
ceux qui ont le pas c'est problématique
parce qu'on se dirige vers un abonnement
au pass vaccinale comme si on était
abonnée au passe navigo 1 parce qu'on
recharge tous les mois avec une dose de
vaccin suisse quant à lui
le problème c'est qu'on gagne à leurs
droits si pour les enfants moi c'est ça
qui me fait un peu peur c'est là j'ai
réussi à revendre et que vous avez des
enfants que la lgv moi j'ai des enfants
qui ont 12 15 et 20 ans est bien en tête
ou pas j'ai pas l'impression reste
je me pose la question non mais
sincèrement je me pose la question j'en
ai un qui est déjà belle sinon tu
voulais mais non mais c'est ma position
j'ai l'impression que c'est en fait une
espèce de politique d'entonnoir aider
pour moi j'ai une question pour m
division officiellement d'après vous
pourquoi est ce que l'état ne rend pas
la chose obligatoire ils ont peur de
quoi une très bonne question il y en a
deux il ya deux éléments de réponse il
ya une réponse choisie fabrier réponse
juridique sur le plan politique à
quelques mois d'une élection c'est un
peu casse gueule de faire ça mais je
vais vous dire je ne suis pas favorable
à l'obligation vaccinale en tant que tel
mais en soi j'aurais compris l'idée
d'une obligation qui disent ou non en
considérant mon but est de protéger la
population je suis d'accord pas d'accord
mais ça s'est promenée démocratie le
dire mais en soit effectivement on met
pas le couteau sous la gorge mais si un
scandale sanitaire par exemple on fait
cela mais admettons il serait dans cette
seconde de la deuxième quinzaine de
juillet dit qu une deuxième raison qui
est juridique parce que le gouvernement
l'a perd pas de vue non plus et ce que
je m'évertue à essayer de vous dire nous
sommes en faveur du roi du développement
et qu'aujourd'hui une obligation
vaccinale en population générale ça ne
s'est jamais vu et encore plus
effectivement avec un nez avec un
médicament ou vaccin en phase iii de
développement la phase iii est pas
achevé ce qui pose un autre problème
une fois que vous avez dit vous êtes
obligé c'est quoi la sanction parce que
toute obligation est assorti d'une
sanction sequana alors je m'étais les
gens en prison jamais la cour européenne
devra comme elle sera passée ça donc
quoi donc donc enfin il va se passer
quoi on va on va vivre ou se passer ni
terre plus ou moins permanent en fait
non mais servir la personne qui n'est
pas vaccinée elle fait comment pour
vivre alors ma soi et dans mon cas c'est
à dire que moi finalement il peut me
confiner 20 ans il peut même un peu toi
pas sanitaire j'ai un mode de vie qui
fait que je m'en fous donc c'est assez
régler si vous voyagez pas je n'en sais
qu'en voyage vous même passé alors je
m'en fous je cherche à être laissé un
truc amidon chaud venu déjà ok j'ai fait
j'ai fait mon test et fin de l'histoire
ces 24 heures maintenant on attend pige
entrée 2 où l'on ferait 3 j'en sais rien
nous faisons le plein de symboles mais
oui mais je m'en fous et 25 balles
placer pas raison mais c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites est sans faille pas de
problème d'argent mais qui peuvent même
même si ça me coûte 3000 euros par mois
je vais vous dire ah ouais j'aurais fais
moi c'est ce que j'ai fait pour aider à
pollock pas faire vacciner on a mis 25
mille euros sur la table nous at-il de
famille vision une cagnotte on a mis à
là nous on a vingt cinq mille euros et
les 25000 euros ils servent à payer les
tests ne seront pas les moyens sur les
paires en point f
donc je vais vous dire s'il faut que je
remette 25000 euros pour payer les tests
de gens n'ont pas les moyens je le ferai
hertz et c'est comme ça mais qu'il est
blessé
au
dire ce que tu tombes assez bon c'est
sûr va nous dire ah si c'est bien sûr
oui surtout à compenser dans les mesures
nouvelles mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement c'est qu'on a la pression
qui il impose des choses mais rien ne
change pour ceux qui se font vacciner il
pousse la vaccination mais en les
vaccinant l'écomusée de faire l'impasse
à un test pcr pour prendre l'avion on
est obligé de porter un masque 20 ans
d'expérience car même si on est vaccinés
dont quoi vacciner ou pas ça change pas
mon cher ça devait se faire à voir
fabrice et son jeu mais l'histoire il
abrite la bri fabrice faillite d'opel et
des formes graves abri énorme édition
très choqué il ya une norme alors ça
vous dites n'importe quoi il ya des
médecins qui nous
amène aux landaises ou faisait pas de
bêtises de gestion mais arrêtez de
récession pèsent sur play non non je
t'arrête gère pas damien fiche de
laisser voter démonté pour tenter
d'écouler ya la tôle à la
division fabrique des bijoux vous avez
dit le 28 le 26 août la dérouler tirages
inédits vacciner génome et ça ça c'est
quoi le salon attend aider oui je suis
vacciné dans sa liste m'appelle et il me
dit vous êtes vacciné je réponds oui on
il a titré fabrice di vizio accès contre
kobe de 19 mais j'ai jamais dit ça donc
oui à la question qui m'a été posée il
ya une espèce de biais de la pense à
vous dès le début il est l'accès des
partis comme
ça mais qu'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la coqueluche at on me
pose la question de la vaccination c'est
uniquement coville 19 qui intéresse est
ce que vous savez au code
s'applique en faux contre la rubéole est
ce que vous savez que la grippe des
enfants ça y est certain
et
soudain qui meurt on s'en fout non mais
ça fait ça le sujet dont on rêve ou pas
c'est pas le sujet
vous passionne on s'en fout parce que
c'est pas le sujet la seule chose qui
leur importante c'est qu'une personne
qui n'est pas vacciné je souhaite
d'aller très bien si par hasard l alcôve
ide et que du coup elle a plus de
chances d'avoir une forme grave cette
personne qui va aller à l'hôpital va
prendre la place d'une personne qui n a
qu signer alors est une autre mathieu on
apprend qu
est ce qui vous permet et je pose la
question favori mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui parce que j'ai vu
énormément de médecins et les médecins
ils sont pas catégorique sur le fait que
les personnes qui sont vaccinées ne font
pas de temps de grave j'ai bien eu des
cas il y avait des pans de grâce sont
des personnes à
problèmes du oui nous y emmener des
métiers la vaccination est une
réponse n'est pas mettre sa bah oui mais
là il pu dire si pour ça vous avez pas
parlé voiture n'était pas répondre comme
un médecin oui le dire ce que je vais
dire c'est que en santé publique le oui
ou le non ça n'existe pas alors oui
maintenant d'apprendre à guéret on a des
moyens de répondre en vérité elle est
toujours au milieu ça n'existe pas le
oui ou le non d'ailleurs rappelez vous
quand ici on avait dix lots de vaccins
et la baguette magique vous avez dit non
ça n'existe pas la baguette magique ça
va a été publié en ces termes dans la
presse j'avais dit ça n'existe pas
quelques mois plus tard j'avais raison
mais interrogeons nous sur un faux je
vois poser une question aux chroniqueurs
vous êtes vacciné depuis combien de
temps saint amand à 6 mois à 6 mois donc
si vous taxez depuis six mois est-ce que
vous vous considérez comme vacciner ou
non vacciner
vous allez payer troisième aujourd'hui
vous vous considérez comment je
considère comme vaccinés oui nous
considérer comme vacciner alors là vous
éclairer que passer cinq mois retraités
café votre balai volant et troisième de
ces faits mais anticorps et suave et
mais si ça change rien les anticorps
dans les magazines avec efficacité
baisse mais ça ne sert au troisième
moi je moi je vais rejouer ya un truc ce
qu'on venait pas tous parlé là dessus
juste une question posée vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé avec cette famille vos
gènes avec les crimes et là dans les
veaux oui et je vous réponde à ça
brillant je ne fais pas je n'ai vu que
ses trois personnes non vaccinées le
fils et les deux parents sont tous morts
onu alors est ce que vous voulez un
exemple effectivement d'un cluster de
vacciner avec environ 40% morts et les
autres qui sont en forme grave donner
plein comme ça si vous voulez faire de
la santé publique sur les exemples on
peut en faire toujours des exemples on a
dit on jamais fait les exemples ci
voulait la casuistique ça n'a jamais
fait une vérité parce que c'est
exactement ce qu'on avait fait gagner
pour la troisième dose c'est bien ça qui
m'embête on dit regardez en israël ça
marche la troisième dose les gars sont
vaccinés depuis un mois et demi je
l'avais dit la même chose fois 2e 12 mai
vous confondez tout ouïe ouïe peuvent
encore avoir le coc vide mais à moins de
temps de grave c'est partout dans toutes
les stats dans tous les journaux
peut-être que zeljko vide aujourd'hui
j'étais payé deux fois sauf que c'est
une vie qui coule que je
suggère dis pas que c'est mérité mais
j'ai un ami belge celsino que jean
brasier hier son oncle vient de mourir
suite à une thrombose suite et quelques
semaines après avoir fait le vaccin
c'est son deuxième en khl qui perd en
trois mois après avoir fait le vaccin
l'hôpital ne veut pas faire une enquête
pour savoir si c'est lié 1010 est en
pleine santé et le son propre médecin
m'a tant fourni mais faute tests pcr
parce que lui-même médecin ne crois pas
ne croit plus efficace que la sa x
bordel ça y est c'est pas bon exemple
non mais j'ai laissé ça fait pas maigrir
faire un bon exemple est une évaluation
du risque et les bleus qui tu choisi de
croire il ya autant d'exemples d'un côté
que de l'autre la norme iso nancy
mécénat mais il ya une part de vérité
là-dedans teaser il ya une part de
confusion en fait est que le problème
des gouvernants c'est qu'à force de
faire de la communication plus que de la
santé on rajoute effectivement de la
confusion à la confusion et ce qui se
passe c'est que du coup quand je n'ai
pas tous les éléments pour discerner
qu'est ce que je fais est bien dans mon
langage tant qu effectivement l'homme
sera homme ça s'appelle une vertu qui
est une vertu cardinale ça s'appelle la
vertu de prudence et la vertu de
prudence et la commandent effectivement
de à ça peut être le vaccin il n'y a pas
de problème moi j'ai pas preuve à cette
idée enfin c'est ce qu'elle dit mais à
une condition c'est qu'effectivement ça
relève d'un choix libre et pas d'un
choix contre un jeune est rien